we gotta get to some s'mores can we eat
s'mores can we smore it please yeah i
can't wait to get to this dessert i
despise okay i would like to introduce
my lovely wife amanda oh my lovely
sister-in-law yay
um ladies thank you so much there's a
mic over there too if you guys want to
say hi really hi everyone that's amanda
that's amanda hello i'm the other one
wow that's sarah with very low
self-esteem
i'm the other one sarah has worked up
something special for us because i hear
i understand sarah's quite talented
she's really talented and wait till you
see this because crafty gal
yeah look at this brings me joy there is
oh my gosh oh my god they are made to
look just like us this is i don't know
if we can get a shot of this but it's
really good that's your pompadour these
are marshmallow effigies and i'm just
realizing now that sona has mini
marshmallow boobies my boobies yes she
does
i love that sarah thank you
i love that you had to point out that
that was my pompadour i didn't think
that was a tumor that no one's had the
guts to tell me about you're very
talented this is really cool do we roast
our own or
burn the effigy of another person you
know well first of all i have to see my
face melt
because and i mean i don't even know
that i can look at this eat this
this is too nice for me to roast look at
that this has the same
muscular density that i have
this is about the strength of my
back
i do want to bite the head of the conan
one off i think you guys should utterly
destroy them can i can i i want to see
mine die on the fire yeah because i've
always i mean i do too should i just
drop mine on the fire and see what
happens put it on a skewer here oh okay
that's a good idea
you have choices
this is the scenario
anybody have an idea as i'm walking
along oh this is how gurley and sona get
rid of conan yeah so i just i'm asking
you guys hey guys oh what's going on
like i said i i guess i'm doing myself
so it could be my voice yeah why why
didn't what was that i don't know i i
just lost it for a second oh uh hey
there matt hey sona what's going on hey
how's it going yeah pretty good all
right hi
just uh anybody i got any ideas i'm
thinking of taking a really safe walk
yeah i don't want to get hurt
there's a lake over there that's going
to look not blue and it's going to be
not refreshing but i think you should
jump in here wait these this this area
over here yeah follow me up until a
certain point and stand right there i
will stop we'll stop you go on well of
course i should go on because uh i'm an
a-lister is that what you mean yeah yeah
only famous people can go there so
listers we'll hang back
okay i'm gonna go over there i trust you
guys okay
we'll walk with you we'll walk with you
to a certain point and then i gotta get
back home all right guys why don't i go
ahead i'll go first okay all right you
guys get back i see paparazzi over there
and they're gonna want me alone oh yeah
okay we'll hang back here you keep going
you keep going you guys are good voting
you keep going yeah they're gonna want
to see yeah yeah you keep going no karen
pick a dress why are you pushing me
hold on hold on hold on let me see i
want to see the
ah are you sure this is a lake yeah yeah
this you're not a bee oh okay you sure
it's a lake finally the volcano is
accepting a virgin
[Applause]
[Music]
oh finally paying in this life
for all my sins high five oh my god look
i
am not dead yet oh it's like you spent
three minutes in the sun
ah
slowed down oh this is my peach is
filling my feet fell off but i can still
i think lead a protective life without
ah crotch completely gone
oh well hasn't worked in a while ah
hi
i oh look at the hair is going oh it's
gonna slide off
[Applause]
oh look
my hair flew on my burnt hair oh no i've
got it on me how do i get it off
here i'll help you get conan off me oh
it's on your head i love you two are
terrible killers
now i'm gonna be the marshmallow csi sir
is that melted conan on your head